well Manzarek no sorry not Mansur he
came later Garret Hardin wrote a very
stirring article in 1968 published in
science and he imagined a pasture open
to all and posited that if that were the
case then everyone would bring their
animals on and they would keep bringing
more and more and more and they would
eventually overuse the Commons what he
went on to say was that that they were
trapped and could not themselves get out
of it and what our theory theoretical
work and empirical work has shown is
that in many instances but not all
people have found ways of agreeing on
their own rules and extracting
themselves from the problem
this concept of pol centricity of
enabling both market and government
governments at multiple scales to
interact with community organization so
that we have a complex nested system and
it ain't pretty in the sense that it's
nice and neat and many people have tried
to get rid of creative solutions that
are complex but society is complex P for
complex and for us to have simple
solutions to complex problems not a good
idea
if the community at play were only the
entire planet and we simply wait until
so big guys make a decision we're in
deep trouble our theoretical work on
Paulo centricity here is very relevant
in that while in any greenhouse gas
emission does have a global effect it
may also have and usually does local and
regional effects so we need to be
thinking about how to enhance the ways
of organizing around the local and
regional so as to produce more
externalities that are positive at the
global
well a great number of the policies laid
down let's take the policies for eastern
Africa related to the pasture area that
the Masai occupied the Masai had been
there for centuries and had figured out
a way of grazing over a great distance
so that in an area where the rainfall
was limited and spotty they were able to
maintain that rangeland in a very good
form they didn't look pretty as that's
the way it was but if you if you graze
down too far and then you let some other
things come up and don't graze in an
area and you get big bushes then you end
up with ruining the functioning of it
well when the brits came in they gave
half of it well shouldn't that not have
they gave a very large segment away to
colonial farmers and to set up a big
reserve the Kenyan government in the
1950s onward kept giving away giving
away giving away they finally created
group ranches but the group ranches
weren't large enough to really enable
them to maintain the kind of system that
worked they then have been privatizing
themselves the the Maasai their land so
it would not be given away again by the
government and working out arrangements
so that family and friends can share and
they're recreating the movement of the
cattle around and Esther Magni has done
a wonderful job of studying this over
time and they may the local people may
again find a way of coping with a very
difficult and challenging environment